1986 Fortune magazine wrote a huge
article 50 biggest and most powerful mob
bosses in the country it's out of that
list of 50 some 33 years later 49 a time
a day I'm the only one that survived my
name is Michael Francis and I was a
former cop okappa regime in the Colombo
crime family back in New York one of the
five New York Mafia the Cosa Nostra
families my dad was the underboss of the
Colombo family his name was Sonny
Franzese my dad was a very highly
publicized figure he was a major target
of law enforcement had a lot of media
attention when I grew up as a result of
that actually hating the police because
I loved my father you know I always saw
them as the enemy you know trying to
hurt my dad trying to hurt my family now
originally my dad didn't want this life
for me he wanted me to go to school be a
doctor I was on that road until my dad
got in some very serious trouble in the
60s in 1966 my dad was indicted in
federal court from masterminding a
nationwide string of bank robberies
after a lengthy trial it was convicted
1967 he was sentenced to 50 years in
prison who has shipped off to
Leavenworth Penitentiary in Kansas to do
his time and I was a pre-med student and
when my dad went away I was devastated
he was 50 years old when he went in
forget 50 on top of that he'd never come
out of prison alive and at that time Joe
Colombo was the boss of our family he
kind of took me under his wing I started
to meet a lot of my dad's friends they
would say to me Mike what are you doing
going to school you don't help you
father out he's gonna die in prison so I
was very impacted by that I went to see
dad and he was pretty upset he didn't
want that life for me originally wanted
me to go on as a professional but he
knew my mind was made up and I was a
pretty headstrong kid he kind of threw
his hands up I'll never forget and he
said all right but if you're gonna be on
the street I want you on the street the
right way he says to me go home somebody
will be in touch with you do whatever
you're told he actually proposed me for
membership in that life you can't just
go up and sell somebody hey I'd like to
join somebody has to propose you they'd
have to vouch for you say you have what
it takes so in my case was my dad next
18 months to two years I was in kind of
like a pledge period I was known as a
recruit I was on call 24 hours a day you
had to do whatever you were told to
prove yourself worthy to become
Halloween night 1975 I was called into a
room with five other gentlemen there was
a very solemn ceremony the six of us
walked into a room individually boss
seated at the head of a horseshoe
configuration walk down the aisle stood
in front of the boss held out my hand he
took a knife cut my finger some blood
dropped on the floor took a picture of a
saint to Catholic altar caught put it in
my hands and lit it aflame and he said
tonight Michael Franzese you are born
again into a new life until the Cosa
Nostra if you betray your oath you
violate your oath you're gonna burn in
hell like the Saint is burning in your
hands do you accept and I said yes I do
I took that old very seriously back then
it's a very serious life and I take it
seriously today even though I don't
consider myself a member of that life
anymore I was motivated to do two things
one I wanted to get my dad out of prison
and two I want them to make money I was
very aggressive on the street I brought
some new things into the family hadn't
been done before so I devised the scheme
to defraud the government out of tax on
every gallon of gasoline I ran that
operation for about eight years and at
the height of my operation I was selling
a half a billion gallons of gas a month
at one point in time we will bring it in
seven eight nine ten million dollars a
week I have my own jet plane I had a
helicopter ride house in Florida at a
house in Marina del Rey California house
in New York I have three hundred guys
under me ready to do anything I tell
them to do I did get my dad out of
prison after ten years he got out on
parole he kept going back he was
violated five times my dad did a total
of 40 years in prison on that 50 today
my dad is released from prison he's a
hundred and two years old he'll be 103
in February tell you where I was in 1984
when things started to make a transition
for me I was probably at the height of
my game my father was grooming me to
take over the family boss underboss
whatever way it worked out I was
indicted five times I had two federal
racketeering cases one brought on by
Rudy Giuliani I was eventually acquitted
in that case I really had it going on at
the age of 29 and among many things I
was doing back then I was making movies
I had a production company in LA and
Smokey Robinson was a good friend he
comes to me with a screenplay for a
breakdance movie so we made this movie
in Florida and I brought in 50
professional dancers to work in the film
was a young dancer by name at Camille
Garcia
I saw her and that was it you know it's
like you had me at hello and as a result
of my falling in love with her and us
being so far apart I mean I'm this mob
guy and she's this young girl of faith I
knew if I wanted her in my life I had to
make some changes I decided to try to
walk away from that life I didn't want
to hurt my former associates but that's
not something that you do when you leave
that life it's considered betraying your
oath and you can pay for with your life
I was willing to take that chance
I took a plea on a big racketeering case
involving this old gas scam that I was
involved in I got a 10-year prison
sentence I married Camille she's now my
wife of 35 years we moved out to
California I go off to do my time as a
result of that I'm in a lot of trouble
immediate contract on my life my father
at the time pretty well disowned me he
was very upset with what I did I had law
enforcement all over me the feds wanted
me to become a major informant major
witness I didn't want any part of that I
had a very rough time in prison I did
five pretty tough years as a result of
that I got out after five years on
parole I'm on parole for 13 months worse
13 months of my life you know basically
dodging bullets a lot of trouble with
the feds still trying to make a living
out in California my wife and I at that
point in time we had two little babies
third one on the way after 13 months
like a fool I make a mistake I fall into
a trap violate my parole they send me
back to prison told me I'd never see the
light of day again I'd never be a free
man that did 29 months in seven days in
the hole
24 hours a day seven days a week I was
in lockdown was during that time that I
became a person of faith studied my
Bible very much and decided that I was
going to really try to make a transition
in my life for the last 23 years I've
been a very prolific speaker both on a
faith-based side and in a secular side I
speak all over the world I've written
four books I'm on my fifth and I've been
extremely blessed to be where I am today
I told you in 1975 there was six of us
that took the oath that night I'm the
only one alive today the other five were
all murdered taking that a step further
1986 Fortune magazine wrote a huge
article 50 biggest and most powerful mob
bosses in the countries out of that list
of 50 some 33 years late
49mm a debt I'm the only one that
survived so to say that I'm a fortunate
blessed guy is really an understatement
and you know I attribute that to God
having a different plan and a purpose
for my life and be meeting this young
girl because her boys and for her I need
to be dead or in prison for the rest of
my life without a doubt like all my
former friends and associates you know I
have to say during my time in that life
I was a committed mob guy and I wanted
to be the best possible mob guy I could
be I wanted to make my father proud and
plus I try to do my best when I'm doing
something but there were times in that
life when I did things that I just did
not feel good about and I'm almost
ashamed to say that I did him anyway I
saw people get killed for the wrong
reasons I saw people suffer for the
wrong reasons
you know unfortunately you can't go back
and change things you can only hope that
you can move forward and do better
the mob life should not be glorified I
always say it's an evil life I'm not
calling a guys evil because I was one of
them and I don't judge people like that
but the life is evil because I don't
know one family of any member of that
life including my own that hasn't been
totally devastated so any lifestyle that
does that to families is an evil
lifestyle you know I just really want to
encourage people that you can't come
back from a bad situation I mean look
everybody predicted my death when I
walked out of prison
everybody from law enforcement to
everybody on the street the important
thing is you got to be held accountable
you got to surround yourself with the
right people because in this life you
are who you hang out with and I have a
wife that holds me accountable I have
children and hold me accountable I have
a church that holds me accountable and
this is the way I stay on the right
track you can come back from a bad
situation you can defeat the odds and I
just want to encourage people to never
give up hope in that regard
[Music]
you
[Music]